lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
realmente digerir la idea de que si
tenemos una fracción siempre y cuando
multiplicamos el numerador y el
denominador por el mismo número pues
vamos a tener una fracción equivalente
pensemos en ello digamos que
multiplicamos el denominador por 2
ese de acá lo vamos a multiplicar por 2
y yo afirmo que siempre y cuando
multiplicamos el mismo número en el
denominador y en el numerador vamos a
tener acciones equivalentes aquí el
denominador es 6 lo multiplica por 2 y
me queda 12 en el numerador es 4 lo
multiplicó también por 2 y voy a obtener
84 por 28 así que yo estoy afirmando que
8 12 a 2 es equivalente a 4 sextos para
visualizar esto
vamos a redibujar esto vamos a poner de
nuevo aquí nuestro entero que está
dividido en seis partes iguales pero
ahora lo voy a dividir en doce partes
iguales
cada una de estas seis partes la voy a
dividir a la mitad que es realmente lo
que es multiplicar este 6 por 2 ahora
tendremos el doble de las secciones
iguales
ahora tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
cuántas de ellas están iluminadas en
amarillo pues son 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 estos
8 de aquí no hay magia aquí si tenemos
el doble de secciones pues vamos a tener
que tener el doble de pedazos que
tomamos para que se conserve la fracción
para que sean equivalentes y también
sucede lo mismo al contrario no es sólo
por la multiplicación también puedo
hacerlo dividiendo si yo he dividido el
numerador y denominador por el mismo
número también voy a obtener una
fracción equivalente es otra forma de
decir bueno qué pasa si divido esto
entre 2
6 / 2
entre dos voy a tener la mitad de los
pedazos que tenía aquí es decir en lugar
de tener seis pues voy a tener tres
pedazos tres secciones iguales y yo
afirmo que si hacemos lo mismo en el
numerador vamos a obtener una fracción
equivalente aquí este 4 lo tengo que
dividir entre 24 entre 2 va a ser igual
a 2 así que yo estoy afirmando que dos
tercios es equivalente a cuatro sextos y
también es equivalente a 812 ambos vamos
a visualizar lo pongamos del nuevo esté
entero acá pero en lugar de tener seis
partes iguales vamos a tener tres partes
iguales así que estas dos de aquí las
vamos a unir para formar una sola esas
otras dos de aquí también las unimos y
estas últimas dos también las vamos a
unir
de manera que tenemos tres partes
iguales en este mismo entero y de estas
tres partes iguales solo dos de ellas
están resaltadas en amarillo así que se
cumple el tener dos tercios todas estas
son fracciones equivalentes así que la
regla es comiencen con una fracción si
multiplican por el mismo número en el
numerador y el denominador van a obtener
una fracción equivalente si ustedes
dividen esa fracción en el numerador y
el denominador por el mismo número
también van a obtener una fracción
equivalente teniendo eso en mente ahora
vamos a resolver un problema de
fracciones equivalentes qué pasa si
alguien nos dice bueno yo tengo 5 entre
25 y yo quiero escribirla como una
fracción una fracción que va a tener un
valor que no conozco y que voy a nombrar
t el valor t en el numerador entre 100
tienen el denominador cual va
el valor de t
en el denominador vemos que para pasar
de 25 a 100 que tengo que hacer pues
tengo que multiplicar por algo y es
multiplicar por 4 y quedamos que si
queremos una fracción equivalente mi
numerador también lo tengo que
multiplicar por 4 que va a ser igual a
20 5 por 4 es igual a 20 así que aquí en
el numerador va a ser 20 quitamos estate
que ya conocemos y ponemos 20 20 entre
100 bueno ahora qué pasa si alguien dice
tengo 5 entre 25 pero yo quiero obtener
una fracción equivalente a algo que está
en blanco que desconozco y que esté
dividido entre 5 bueno que harían
ustedes pensándolo bien mejor vamos a
hacerlo del otro lado vamos a tener un 1
en el numerador y ahora nuestra
interrogante va a estar en el
denominador que necesitamos hacer a este
5 para que se vuelva un 1 pues tengo que
dividir esto entre 555 va a ser igual a
1 y si hago algo en el numerador tengo
que hacer lo mismo en el denominador es
decir tengo que dividir el denominador
entre 5 entonces
20 55 cuánto va a ser pues 55 por 525
así que mi interrogante va a ser 51
entre 5 un quinto es equivalente a 525
abós que es equivalente a 20 entre 100